[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
friday september 9th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
so many of the products and services we
buy today rely on tech running behind
the scenes to deliver them faster more
efficiently or directly to us skipping
the middleman
forerunner ventures is well aware of
this the 10 year old venture capital
firm concentrates on consumer-focused
tech startups it's invested in companies
like fintech firm chime health tech
brand aura and gamer platform medify
but now amid an economic downturn that
follows the rush of vc funding that
poured into startups over the last few
years
how are vcs thinking about what to
invest in next
and how can they help the startups
they've already backed
to discuss this and more we're joined by
kirsten greene the founder and managing
partner of 4runner ventures hi kirsten
thanks for joining us thank you so much
zoe for having me on today
so forerunner typically invests in
consumer focused startups given
inflation given the kind of economic
uncertainty we have at the moment what
kinds of things are you focused on now
you know i think one of the things about
investing in venture capital is you
really do need to take a long view of
the market
our job is to think about what is going
to be incredibly relevant a couple of
years out but has enough relevancy today
that there's an early audience for it
and to get traction
so we think very much less about what's
happening in the moment in terms of the
economic cycles and more about where's
the consumer at what does that maybe
imply about the need or the opportunity
going forward and investing into that
you know we've heard from some other vcs
that now is the time to batten down the
hatches there's been some real warning
messages coming out from other investors
saying you know startups need to cut
back after years of this big boom this
spending spree hiring sprees
it sounds like you're not really in that
camp though we are in that camp but i
don't think that's just blanket advice
for everybody to say
you know the world has changed stop
spending start cutting
i think coming off of the last two years
where we've been in a time period of
tremendous growth
which has meant
tremendous growth in team sizes
tremendous growth in marketing budgets
tremendous mandates to grow in general
as companies like that sort of requires
most everybody to take a hard look at
those elements of their business and say
do we really need
all of the spend that we've accumulated
in the last two years if we're in a
period where it's not just growth growth
growth it's
more holistic about all elements of your
business
and with an asterisk around you've got
to figure out how to
have some opportunity to control your
own destiny you know there's
been a number of layoffs announced i
know people are looking you know closely
again at their cost structures decisions
about people are really hard to make
they're personal and they also you know
any team that grew quickly or hired a
lot of people or any people spent a lot
of time doing that so these are you know
they feel like
challenging decisions to make when you
bring the human element into it but in
so many ways it's you know required
right now as you think about how to
again create the flexibility and the
nimbleness in your business
are there areas that you've seen
startups may be more willing to
negotiate on than they were over the
past few months or a few years you know
it's interesting right now because i
think what hasn't been as clear this
year is
that question around
you know
how much
negotiating room either side has on on
deals and i think a lot of that has to
do with the fact that
companies raised a considerable amount
of money over the last two years and so
there's been less businesses that i
think have been in a situation where
they need to raise capital they've
decided this is the right moment to
raise capital
and i feel like that combination is
really going to extend this question
into 2023.
i think there's going to be more
companies in the market looking for
follow-on dollars in 23 than there were
in 22
and those are really the opportunities
that will create the data points to
understand
how valuations have have changed
so what would you want to get from
companies that are looking for funding
in 2023 i mean what kind of things are
you looking to see and to get from them
in return for your capital
the focus at least on our team i think
we've always focused on unit economics
even very early
different environments require you to
have more evidence of that than others
so even if you have an idea of like okay
here's the business model we kind of
understand how this is going to play out
we can take some leaps and assuming on
how it's going to play out i think
people are less willing to take those
leaps and they want to see more proof
points
and part of that is because i think that
is not just the uncertainty in the
market that maybe tests the belief but
it's just seeing how founders operate
like are they
aware of the environment around them and
balancing the right set of elements and
does that build conviction in their
ability to grow a business in a state of
uncertainty because nobody knows like
how long this period is going to last or
whatever but like the real opportunity
for everybody right now is to kind of
demonstrate your execution capabilities
and the real potential of your business
based on fundamentals
all right i want to end by talking about
a space that i've heard you're a
believer in the metaverse can you tell
us a bit about that maybe some of the
investments that you're making any
opportunities that you see here
our north star in investing is the
consumer we really think about
what's going on with people how are
their lives changing how are their needs
changing and then where can business
solve those and address those the
metaverse is
curious to us and interesting it's
another dimension it's another way for
people to engage and interact
i think we've been
you know impressed or at least inspired
by
many different potential applications
that said it doesn't yet seamlessly
integrate into consumer experience or
people's lives
and i think that we really need to find
a bridge
to bring it into the broader mainstream
can you explain that idea a bit more
that bridge to consumers what do you
mean by that for instance like last year
there was so much conversation and so
much enthusiasm over nfts you know it
captured entrepreneurs imagination it
captured investors imagination and with
the billions of dollars of transactions
that happened on platforms like openc
and others it clearly captured some
people in the markets attention
i think though that there still remains
a big question on like okay what is it
what do i do with this what's the useful
application of this
and i think that
the bridge could be in unlocking
something like an nft
that is less about an advanced jpeg and
more about
a tool for access to
a loyalty program or to
your you know club membership that you
bought or to you know different version
of like executing a subscription model
something that is sort of like we're
doing elements of this today in other
ways in a business
what blockchain or the technology that
these nfts sit on for example offers is
a better way to execute those
experiences with a twist that unlocks
more potential going forward
all right kirsten green from 4runner
ventures thank you so much for joining
us zoe thanks so much for your
thoughtful questions
and that's it for tech news briefing
this week our producer is julie chang
our supervising producer is chris
sinsley our executive producer is kateri
yokum and i'm your host zoe thomas
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
[Music]
you